These desert ants are on a mission:...
...find food and bring it home no matter the size and shape.
But new research suggests ants walking backwards...
...are as good at navigating to their destination as forward-walking ants.
This means they must somehow measure the length of each stride they take,...
...or use other cues to keep track of their location, the researchers say.
When ants find something too large to be lifted and carried forward,...
...they drag it backwards.
So, the researchers put the ants' reversing navigation skills to the test.
They painted a white grid onto the desert floor...
...and released an ant with a large food crumb,...
...and it began its backward track towards its home.
The research published in the "Journal of Experimental Biology"...
...use high-speed camera recordings.
It found that backward-traveling ants showed surprising flexibility...
...with inter-leg coordination...
...in comparison with the forward-walking ones.